[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
would you ever have sympathy sex with
someone
like would you throw someone a bone that
you're not that attracted to
well she's attractive i'm saying
i'm i'm relating something that's not
necessarily related to this i'm just
saying would you would you ever throw
like i don't know i never have um
you never like
you know i'm not she's not but she's
sounds like you have
because that's not where my brain was
going with this and i was thinking of
like this real homely girl one time on a
cruise that i was like yeah i knew i
knew it was because of personal
experience some girl you boned on a
cruise some pig who needed it
dude and the next day i ignored her
she's standing next to me
i can't believe you've never told me
this i've known 13 years 14 years ago am
i going to bring it up on the podcast
about our
i want to know so was she real fat was
she ugly no she was just like i block
anybody i got a trip i got a [ __ ]
hair
trigger a finger it's if you if you
don't
know uh if if you don't know me then how
do i know how you mean something yeah so
you better come correct
and if you don't then i'll block you and
i don't and i'll forget about who are
you first of all second of all
afterwards who are you you're you know
me you're the guy who somebody messages
me
hey man will you guys delete the unrest
good by the way you should block that
person
okay like what are you talking about you
don't know me the idea though that i'm
gonna be like hold on a second yeah yeah
craig hey chris yeah you know craig on
instagram he said that he should unblock
him
you should reply all those to all those
guys and say chris blocked me i can't i
know
we were talking about this me and you we
don't because bert likes it we talk
about when people come up we don't like
it right yeah yeah yeah i'm just not i
don't mean to speak for you but no no no
i'm like i first of all i'm super nice
to everybody of course yeah like anybody
says anything to me i'm always nice of
course i'm saying that
he relishes yeah yeah yeah he courts it
i wouldn't even say
we went to the national championship
game
uh with uh ari and man
people would be like hey burt he'd be
like you want a picture
like ask them if they want to take a pic
and then they'd be like all right and
then he would be like they're like all
right
i used to open with for joe a lot you
know i travel with him and i feel like
even though he's so famous now when i
look back he felt that even though he
wasn't as famous he felt super famous
whenever we would be in public
interesting you know i mean like yes
yeah so like like everybody it felt like
everybody even 10 years ago was like hey
yeah yeah every day yeah yeah and um
after shows if we would go out or
something there would always be weird
guys yeah you know and i think it's like
you guys weirdos yeah and they would be
like joe he'd be like yeah
yeah
like
and they would linger and he'd be like
the [ __ ] are you doing here you know
and they would go away i would laugh
every time and one time we went to this
restaurant in san jose after the show
and um
there's some weirdos and and this guy
was like
hey man he's like what'd you say and uh
you know the guy
kind of said something he was like oh
okay well we're going to eat now so you
know
get out of here or something and the guy
was like no no but he was like dude what
are you doing like what do you do
and then we sat in these booths at this
restaurant and the guy jumped in the
booth no
must have sensed that on some level
and then with one hand pushed them all
out he went
like that and the guy went flying out of
the booth wow like
launched him out of the booth and
yeah and then the guy was like well all
right just took off this is not an
exaggeration
eight or nine out of ten times
they come up they say something
insulting oh right right like yeah
they don't
and i understand i understand you know
we lose track because we're around
people that we uh think are are funny
all the time but they're like oh oh this
is the only this is i get to see a
comedian i like i never have seen that
right so i get that they get the motor
mouth thing whatever you want to call it
but like they'll be like oh my god like
like um
man oh dude i always try to [ __ ] my
friends [ __ ] hate you and i always
but i always stick up for you
like that and you're like and i'm like
and i'm and i know but and so if that
happens i i'm not nice to you because
you have to understand that what you
just did yeah yeah no i agree yeah so i
say did you just come up here tell me a
bunch of people don't like me
well no but i do yeah exactly no i'm
trying to say oh man and just say you're
then at that point just say oh [ __ ] i'm
sorry i didn't know what to say but that
never happens they're like no no no i
just got and
i remember one time you you remind you
know you remind me of like i'll be like
what you know you remind me of who
uh that guy
uh from the hangover i'm like zach
galifianakis yeah i'm like why because
we have beards yeah they're so dumb
other funny people yeah they think are
actually funnier than you yeah yeah yeah
you know who's really funny
yeah oh yeah oh yeah one thing i love
though you have this i've seen joe do
this too
is that you guys
as soon as somebody is like lingering in
an annoying way like if they're if
they're being tom's told me about it
i
i i don't like it about myself that if
someone's like hey man big fan i'll be
like oh thanks and then uh you know i'll
sit down and they're like
hey you remember the episode and i'll be
like what's that and they'll start like
you're you said the time i'm like uh
yeah okay
thanks man and then i'll turn back down
and they're like does christina really
like it when you and i'm like oh you
know like deal with all this yeah i'll
do the whole thing and i'm so nice i
will stand there and i'll be like yeah
that's great
all right and then you know at worst
i'll just i'll be like i gotta i'm
actually late and i'll walk okay what
you and joe i've seen you both do this
is like someone's like like we were
having coffee and that guy was like i'm
a big fan of you guys and i was like
we were both like oh thanks a lot we
both said thanks a lot he's like you
know it's a tough time you're making us
laugh we're like that's thank you very
much and then he walked away yeah and
then he was like if you ever want like
uh
wrist belts
yeah uh
fingered thumbs it was we were like yeah
and then i was like oh that's cool and
then he walked away again and came back
and was like here's my card and i was
like okay and chris was like yeah thanks
a lot so
and he just completely dismissed it and
i was like oh my god and i i got jealous
how do i get today i don't i didn't even
think that that was a
i'm i thought i was being nice by the
way that that because i'm like you get
you get two and it's great and i'm nice
i'm nice for two for two but like
sometimes two but sometimes it's nice
for two there's this one can we make a
hat this
holy [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] hilarious and i go oh
thanks she goes but i'll laugh at
anything
that makes me mad
and then her friends are like she's a
[ __ ] idiot yeah so she said that
thing don't i go no no no i i get it
it's fine it's fine yeah i've had a
bunch of those man i've had a bunch of
those that are you're just they're just
like
you kind of want to go do you know i
also my my pet peeve one is i find it
super annoying it's like you walk let's
say
uh from a club into like the ship bar
room most people are gone there's no
people
you know or maybe it's like the hotel
across the street and like somebody will
be like oh they're like yeah they go
pretty funny oh
that's rude that's nice i
yeah that drives me nuts because it's
like yo i they're in my head they're
like
i got [ __ ] too yeah i mean like i'm good
at my job yeah like oh you're cool now
you just bought a ticket to see me and
you left your ass off and now you're
gonna be cool you're gonna be cool
that to me is the equivalent of
literally looking at someone and being
like you're not bad looking and you're
like what oh yeah you want to be like
hey man you don't know you're being like
this and somebody that loves you should
tell you yeah but you're a [ __ ] weird
tall lanky guy just hooking over in onto
my shoulder yeah just step back a few a
few paces turn around and talk to the
person in the other direction right if
you know them right but but but because
it's the comedy store and literally and
i'm not trying to toot my own horn like
i'm whatever say what you want about me
but there's there's comedians there that
are [ __ ] like world-class comedians
and i see [ __ ] talk to them and
that's like talking about talking of
being at a cardinals game and talking
about pull holes yeah in between and
you're like dude let it bad yeah let it
bad
okay
so
so
so i'm hanging out at the comedy store i
haven't seen [ __ ] two or three of
these guys in a long time he used to
work with him it was so awesome and
there's a [ __ ] tall lanky guy hooking
over right and i feel this and i turn
around and he's now he is starting
conversation which is okay fine i want
to say one or two things right thanks
and then
it goes off from me and he just he's in
the conversation now and he's driving
the conversation okay and i haven't seen
these people and the people that i
haven't seen are like do you know this
guy to me right so now i look like i
have weird [ __ ] friends all right
yeah so
so i want them to know he's not my
friend i want him to know that he
shouldn't be doing this anymore right
okay
and so he tells a joke
and my other friends laugh all right and
it's not funny all right they do like a
courtesy yes and and i went like i went
like this
i said
[Laughter]
i said who are you
[Laughter]
that's amazing
and
dude
my friends
laughed so hard because they thought
we were friends right and in that moment
they realized oh this was just a god
this guy just walked out and and i s and
i went
my worst
nightmare job is to be on like csi
and
for eight seasons be rich as [ __ ] but be
that [ __ ] guy where you're like i'm
way ahead of you to type in yeah you
know what i mean
my brains out i flew with uh what's the
guy that played uh chris noth played mr
b oh yeah yeah that sex in the city so
we were talking all about this stuff and
he goes
he said um he's like he's like you know
that role is like it's fine or whatever
and then he goes um he was on law and
order yeah yeah how was you know how did
you like that he goes well
he's like it you know gave me a lot of
financial security but he's like
every week it's the same different and
you just go like
you're like we need to talk to that guy
now
and then
you walk in and you're like sit down and
then like he's like it's just repeat
every week he's like there's nothing
there he's like you know what i want to
be on it was like downton abbey that's
what yeah he's like you know where
there's like actual real things
happening yeah like there's a
there's the drama swells and the snakes
are like and he's like it's just like
brilliant writing he's like this long
order [ __ ] man
and then he got
he got mad
at the uh there was a there was a flight
attendant yeah who freaked out that he
was on the plane because he's you know
women women know
she saw him she started to shake and he
was like god damn it
i was like uh
he's like he's like not with american
airlines this [ __ ] delta [ __ ]
they're obviously not professional when
she did that he should have just said
sit down sit down
have you seen
you've seen larry king talk about mark
wahlberg no you didn't see that oh man
oh no wait wait wait
starring alongside mark wahlberg and
rose byrne in instant family all right
you share the screen with mark
wahlberg yeah you got it i got it
know him a long time what was that like
so
it's a crazy right that's crazy
that he but then we all right you know
what's
more
wallburgers no that's just that okay
that's i know what's great about you is
[Laughter]
you saying
yeah you got it the way you said it
you legitimately could have said any uh
words in the world you could have said
i have a lamborghini
and and it doesn't matter we all knew
what you meant
and that's
that you often have that you often have
we know what you're saying no matter
what you're saying and that's a true
talent oh that's a true talent
you know how hard it is to actually pick
the words to make somebody understand
what you're saying and you don't even
need to do that that's x-men [ __ ]
thanks man
what we found that then blew me away
because i love that larry did this so
much of course yeah um and and he's got
other ones which we'll get to but uh
that that apparently wahlberg's name has
been something that people stammer on
all the time oh really have you got a
favorite movie you've watched chelsea
my favorite i've watched the last few
days is called spencer confidential with
mark uh
i mean
and then uh i mean i don't know if
you've even seen that this guy
i'm doing it because i know
wahlberg you know what i mean what did i
do say it again but uh so that
i'm doing it because i like mark
wahlberg
sends you this [ __ ]
we have research minions and then for
[ __ ] sake the only one what is bert
wearing dude this is the only one that
tops that one okay is this one how do
mark wahlberg
[Music]
[Music]
you